spring is in the air the perfect season
for BMW to launch the successor to its
one series convertible the two series
convertible is just over 7 centimeters
longer than its predecessor but it's
retained the brand's typical proportions
with little overhang a long hood long
wheelbase and broad toe
product manager Paloma Schmidt break
link says what really sets the car apart
from its forbear is the discrete design
larger dimensions and enhanced luxury
the silhouette is longer with flat
shoulders and a very small rear that's
why it handles great and looks so sporty
she says even one part since its
introduction in 2008 130,000 units of
the 1 series compact convertible have
been sold the 2 Series convertible is
flatter and longer and the 1 Series
three and five-door models roll bars are
hidden inside the headrests and back and
a new construction material has gone in
the cars retractable roof Paloma says
BMW was able to reduce ambient noise by
5 to 7 decibels by adding insulation the
soft top can be open and closed in just
20 seconds at speeds up to 50 kilometers
an hour so you don't have to pull over
just to put the top up or down a nice
feature it means you can react almost
instantly to sudden changes in weather
with the top down the new model also has
20 more liters of volume in the trunk
than its predecessor for more cargo
space owners can lower the rear seats
our test car was fitted with the brand
Sportline interior that includes accents
like red seats red seams on the steering
wheel and red highlights on the door
panels customers can also choose from
the advantage luxury line or m-sport
packages our car sports the 228 eye
inline four-cylinder gasoline engine
that packs 180 kilowatts the automatic
transmission eases up to 100 kilometers
an hour in 6 seconds and top speed of
250 the new 2 Series Convertible has
already gone on sale in German
dealerships now the weather just has to
play along
you